I always felt like you never accepted
who I was so I had to be who I am
somewhere else whether that's manifested
in gangs or whatever you know and my mom
like was like I'm sorry for the way I
raised you and I was like what
[Music]
oh good thing we're
currently currently off the Record uh
try that again make it no leave it
because we don't do retains we don't do
edits here bro here's the thing
it's over I think take a second take a
second and think about throughout the
course of your life who are some people
that you were totally wrong about George
W bush
what do you mean what did you think
about him and then where were you wrong
no is this [__] joke what do you mean
you should be a George W bush big fan
you really were huge fan yeah right you
didn't hate I felt like everyone in our
generation hated his you actually liked
him well after 9 11 I was like we got a
[__] let's go oh oh so you were
indoctrinated I was brought into the
system CA FBI I thought those guys were
like like the front line for America to
be fair I was with him and I only said
because remember all Vietnamese people
are Republicans by way of the war so no
matter what even my parents my parents
had a George W bush [__] photo hang
in our living room wow like I voted for
George W bush too because my church said
to me too really yeah we were Bush
People yeah I was I think church people
usually are well our church didn't speak
of any politics oh so I was surprised I
think it's just my youth pastor maybe
you gotta vote Bush I mean the reason
why I laughed not so much about war
stuff now is because I really was like
like I thought it was all like legit and
[__] like I really did I really but you
feel duped and then yeah hurt because of
that yeah and I believe my government I
believe the wmd lie [__] all that
stuff I used to look I even thought that
like anybody who even questioned 911 not
like oh my God like that me like we all
know don't look at me not like we all
know for a fact that it was a conspiracy
I just mean that they use 911 as an
excuse to to do all kinds of [__] up
and now you've changed your mind
absolutely like 9 11 didn't have it no
no that's you I think 911 happened but I
think that they used they used it as an
excuse to do [__] up [__] make tons of
money for themselves which they always
do with everything so but now I'm more
cynical about the world than I didn't
used to be I used to be rah-rah let's go
USA [__] stuff so yeah definitely
wrong about that wow that's a pretty big
to admit actually I can't wait to admit
it gwb or George W bush is the biggest
the biggest warmonger of my life Wow ham
Rumsfeld Cheney all those guys scumbag
war criminals 100 Obama's a war criminal
trumps will work criminal like I'll
never believe those guys ever again any
of them hey dude I [__] salute you
buddy let's go brother thank you for
your service that's tight that's
gangster [__] anybody else have a person
that comes tonight totally wrong for me
it's not necessarily
individuals but my
um I was wrong about how people will
respond and react a lot so for example I
thought that like
most people had this desire to do
something for themselves break out and
whatever and all they needed was a
chance all they needed was a bit of
resources and whatever and then now I've
come to realize that uh people are their
own demise in most cases in most most
cases where you see someone
um in a bad state or they [__] up or
they didn't succeed or they couldn't get
somewhere like I'll it's like for
example right like let's say someone's
like
down and out and you feel bad for them
but then you talk to their family
members they burnt so many people that
no one would want to offer them their
couch anymore you heard you just there's
just like they were so mean that that's
why they're alone on Christmas and
they're just all these things right so
you're just like wait a minute like
should we feel sorry for this person
because they burnt every single person
that loved them and now they're getting
what they deserve because of how they've
basically dug their own grave and I and
I think like the older I get the less
kind of sympathy and empathy I start
having because it's so
this pattern is like you are doing this
for yourself where you see this in
people that are like hey you know you're
causing like people to run away from you
because you're so controlling or like
other things like that yeah is there a
specific
person or situation not necessarily it's
just an observation so like I've grown
to become a little colder where before
it used to be like oh everyone if they
say like I want to do this I want to do
that I'm gonna give you an opportunity
I'm gonna give you this but then like
put them on track even people that are
not motivated are just like come on dude
I want to motivate them you can do it
and whatever and then I realized like
everybody it's just on them huh they
have their own
um
they they lock their own selves up in
their heads so like we I feel like we
share the same Physical Realm but their
reality is so [__] different and I
didn't realize that I didn't realize how
different their world was I just thought
it was kind of similar and everyone had
hopes and dreams and then you just have
to like
kind of nudge them this way and then
they they're like oh I see it now I'm
gonna go and do it but then like now I'm
like whoa like no people are like living
in completely different realities I know
what I'm talking about there's times
where I'm like oh man this thing really
helped unlock this part of my life for
me I can't wait to pass it on and then
you want to pass it on but then you
realize when you pass it on it doesn't
necessarily
help the other person because they have
to unlock it for themselves that's
that's what I mean yeah because there's
times where like you're like oh man if I
had known this when I was this age
things would have been way better or way
different you can't pass down the
Breakthrough [__] yeah I wanna yeah but
the Breakthrough has to happen
themselves no matter how much you try to
help nothing's breaking yeah and I'm not
trying to like blame the victim right
because there's like people that are
literally in shitty situations since
they were born like they were just
abandoned nobody look like loved them
like it's just a really hard [__]
life but I'm talking about like
generally generally I've seen time and
time again people [__] their own lives
up and and and and I'm just sitting
there going like what the [__] like I
like when people are like getting fired
or like like all these things right it's
like yeah because they stole from the
company or they did some you know I'm
like and then they're just wondering
like why the world's kicking them around
it's like maybe you shouldn't have stole
from the company Maybe Should Have
Cheated on the person that you loved
what about the employees that like get
like pay cuts
they deserve it maybe you should have
worked hard
[Music]
that's what my line says yeah they're
being entitled that's what my lines is I
was being it's my fault oh you know who
uh who I was wrong about
my mom
um oh in a yeah yeah I remember you said
yeah like my so for the month of
December my mom pretty much stayed with
us if you know like my whole Dad's
passing thing so like she just doesn't
feel comfortable at her house and all
that stuff so we're like yeah come on
over hang out with us change the energy
and stuff so
um during that month even when I come
here to film my mom is in Vegas with Geo
and taika and they're just like living a
life and
um my mom really got to know taika
because during covid she was stuck in
Taiwan for two years and her and Geo
really bonded and throughout my whole
life
um I've always had like this kind of
like
kind of like a resentment and distance
with my mom so I just feel like my
upbringing was so weird and different
and so controlling that I never felt
like if [__] ever happened I didn't feel
like my mom was someone I could run home
to I always feel like I just have to
make it happen on my own and then so
um now that me and my mom are more
reacquainted she's been like saying how
like oh she would like like it more if
like I texted her more or if like we're
like close you know
and I was explaining to my mom like that
distance that you feel it's a result of
how our relationship was since we were a
kid and that was a conversation
first of all I never thought we would
ever have that's how [__] mature I
would never be able to imagine that by
the way but yeah I never thought that
would even be like a conversation we
could have to begin with I thought it
was just going to be she passes or iPass
or whatever and we're just gonna have
this distance for the rest of our life
um but I let her know that it's it's a
result of uh the extreme controlling and
all that stuff that that we had um that
I had growing up and then she was like
oh look what do you mean I was like oh I
don't know like how about bringing an
eight-year-old to the temple to how to
be a monk for a day I was like that's
normal my mom's trying to busting up
laughing like crazy like she just I
think it was so absurd to hear it now
now that she's like out of that mindset
yeah she's laughing at your pain yeah I
was like yeah I was like a
eight-year-old like four a.m bowing on
the floor all the way up to the mountain
for like a mile and coming back I'm like
is that [__] normal and it's just I
was like laughing I'm like or like uh oh
does this remind you of anybody and I
went to the TV I was like I wonder
anybody watch TV today hi it's a mom and
then oh I see someone someone did watch
the TV they peel back the tape and now
then you beat the [__] out of the camera
I was like dying of laughter
this is good this is progress I was like
I was like from all of that I was like
even in the early days of JK I'm wearing
red underwear for like 10 years of my
life and she told me I have to wear it
so even after I was past my 20s
because good luck good luck or some [__]
come on Steve but the cool thing is
I blocked out some things like you did I
think I think she started to see right I
think finally from like her age now like
looking at the lens of where it was back
then
and uh in the beginning I think most
people are defensive oh but it's because
of this I was like you know I'm like a
single mom
or whatever
blame you Mama
I'm not blaming
sequence of events caused the
relationship that we have now is this
gonna be the future I don't know yeah
but the reason why like I'm not
lovey-dovey the way like Jill's brother
is with Geo's mom like like he's herak
because she's always been fully
accepting of who he is I always felt
like you never accepted who I was so I
had to be who I am somewhere else
whether that's manifested in games or
whatever you know and my mom like was
like I'm sorry for the way I raised you
and I was like what I thought she was
gonna laugh again
dude
but that's oh that's crazy kind of
expanding on what I was saying is that
like she cultivated that relationship
and she wants something that she didn't
work for yeah so then now it's like when
you called her out on that she realizes
took responsibility and now there's
progress right and what I mean by people
are their own demise is if you call them
out on that they'll deny it they'll
they'll they won't take responses
excuses they'll still feel entitled to
whatever they want while never changing
who they are and I think that's the
that's the thing that I'm I'm I I've
seen is like so now from that point you
and your mom can move forward and have a
different
like staging your relationship yeah yeah
and I'm like I can't I keep seeing this
pattern every [__] time everywhere I
go with so many humans that I'm like
damn this is like probably one of the
biggest reasons why people are just
stuck at where they're stuck at you know
I was wrong about you is is my wife
because I actually like like when I
first met her we were doing this comedy
group and like I didn't know
um well there's also a thing too where
she's a very attractive person so it was
like I like I didn't like I had a
girlfriend at the time and I didn't want
to like make anything weird ever so I'd
mostly like like you know Buster balls
and stuff which you know that's like in
my family that's like what you do yeah
like you bust balls because like that's
how you show affection we do that in
this room but then people are like man
they hate each other it's crazy that's
why we keep seeing each other every year
but no that's why you've been busting my
balls
I'm talking about gel not you
no but um yeah I definitely didn't
realize how smart Nikki was like when I
first met oh interesting because she
used to play this character like on the
totally sketch days that we were like
the bimbo the stupid bimbo chick and I
it's not that I thought she was actually
dumb it's just like that was my
introduction to her and like like but on
set she was really cool and all this
stuff but we didn't really get to know
each other until like a couple years
into that thing like where we actually
had private time with each other like
doing on set and like actually getting
to hang out and talk and stuff and not
just in a group setting where everyone's
[__] around yeah so that definitely
was eye-opening for me what's that
distance between like seeing her as this
like character that's kind of a dumb
bimbo but her actual genius it's crazy
yeah it's insane it's like she's not
just like normal she's a genius yeah she
is because honestly like the first time
I met her I was like oh she just seems
really nice she's really cool but then
the last time she was on the show I
realized I was like oh she's like a
savant she is a Survivor yeah yeah like
I got to see it when she started talking
a little bit about poker I was like oh
[__] like she's on another level goes
deep she's like lapping her own IQ
number yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I know
she just doubled up oh she's so smart so
yeah it's one of those things too where
you're like oh yeah I remember but I
remember like the the change of like how
I saw her how I know her and I love it
it's been awesome that's cool man one
really sad uh I haven't really like
talked about this publicly because it's
so like sad but like oh another death no
it's kind of but it's like oh it's not a
death more of a maiming so like when I
was like when I first started breaking
uh there was this like uh b-boy that I
looked up to he was like a uh he's like
a star b-boy basically like a dance
royalty we would regard him as that his
name's b-boy crumbs it's like legendary
and uh so growing up when I would go to
my first b-boy jams like I would ask him
for a photo like my disposable camera
and I was like a big fan of this guy
context is a Legendary Legendary you
could download his video off of Napster
at the time he was one of those ogbs
he's like really like a a pillar of like
creativity and breaking uh Game Changer
obviously and then um so like
I always like looked up to him like me
and D-Trix that we all have is like
videos and stuff like his physical DVDs
like we'd buy all of his [__] and uh and
just follow his career and then once we
had made it to ABDC 2009
uh somebody had started on a b-boy forum
a topic about Quest group like being
just total like [__] that we just like
completely sucked and we're just like
not real b-boys no we're just fraud it's
so funny and I was like who the [__]
would sell this [__] and it was him and
uh and then I I just like it like broke
my heart dude I was just like what the
[__] and you never meet your Heroes and
the thing is that it wasn't it wasn't
the thing that I was wrong about isn't
that like Oh I thought he would be a fan
of me I didn't think that
it's that his claims of why we were bad
were so unfair it was like he was just
jealous of you guys yeah because we had
been um like there was this one episode
where we had to dance to a Britney
Spears song and he said that was so unbe
boy for us to do that sold out but like
he's he was a [__] Christina Aguilera
dancer and we thought that was great and
we were maybe that's why he was like
yeah Britney Spears is Tupac Christina
aguera she's the gangster she's
underground but like she's done all the
things that he was honest about and plus
like like Victor one of my crewmates he
did like one-handed hops which at the
time was already a universal move and he
said that Victor bit him directly which
by the time like
tons of people are doing that but no
one's getting [__] he was giving [__] to
us and I wrote back on the Forum and I I
just explained like this is I couldn't
be more disappointed at this moment to
just like write back to you in this
light and just tell you like you better
clap back [__] yeah right and it wasn't
like so much of a clap back it was it
was just like I I had just forgotten
that yeah the best b-boys don't
necessarily make the best people oh yeah
that's hella true and it was and then
that's what I was wrong about as a whole
I was like I always thought like oh look
at these star B boys they must be great
quality people and majority of them are
not especially at the time uh arguably
like at the time when b-boying wasn't a
sustainable career monetarily yeah you
had a lot of like bum b-boys that were
like amazing but had very bad life
choices
and then that's that's not that's to
their disadvantage being that there's no
market like I understand that but also
at the same time like there are b-boys
that were legendary that were very happy
for us and very supportive and that
we're on the same crew as this guy but
his personal Vendetta against us was
like he just to finally be at a level
where you think your hero could respect
you and that's what you got that's so
weird and closed-minded for such a
successful industry b-boy like I thought
he had it all this dude was also in like
you got served like he was doing like
work in the industry and he's the guy
straight up like when when even b-boys
like hardcore dance culture underground
blah blah if you're [__] like fully
commercialized you're doing like pop
celebrity work and stuff usually all
those casts are like pretty open-minded
they understand it's not a sellout it's
a lifestyle like you you can't you can't
always just be Nation authentic and then
also hope to make like an entire
livelihood and support your family off
that it's it's a give and take right
it's like it's like you might be in love
with like Jiu Jitsu and like the
accommodation so but at the same time
you got to teach newbies like that's
part of the culture you know what I mean
in a big a big part of it honestly is
like as a as a vulgar is this to say
it's just because we were we just
weren't sucking anyone's dicks to be
honest because we weren't part of their
clicks and we shot up kind of
unexpectedly before they gave us the
okay so they were like who are these
guys they're not real b-boys but it's
not like we didn't but we didn't
disrespect them like we [__]
worshiped these dudes and the sad thing
is that because he's the one saying that
and he's so influential it caused a lot
of people in that Community it's just
not like us by default I see Chrome said
you guys are whack then you're whack did
he did he ever respond to what you said
to him he did and it was kind of like he
just kind of doubled down mildly on what
he had said but then at the end he was
like but thank you for supporting me and
my crew for so many years and I was like
that's because he turned you into a fan
I guess yeah have you ever met him in
person you guys ever taught I don't know
if he do people's ever baby boys are a
fist fight
very rarely I'd be like man [__] you
we're gonna meet at the park you know
what's funny hey we're gonna [__] it up
some of the most frequent free sites at
b-boy jams what happened between the
Ted's Planet freaks oh really yeah well
they're trying to fight everybody that's
but but it was but it was more people
that were trying to fight them oh really
all right but yeah the uh I did run into
him a few times but I don't think he
knows my face like that oh because he
just sees the crew maybe yeah I don't
think he can like I I don't know because
he's never addressed me like to my face
all of you guys profile he has your
poster on his [__] wall like he's a
hardcore fan you know that that's such a
weird concept because like when you um
get to that level when like a culture or
or an entire community refers to you as
like an OG or a legend or whatever
there's like this pedestal that you're
on but there's also like that same
height of the pedestals like how hard
that fall can feel sometimes you know
what I mean when you get that from some
of your Heroes your Inspirations when
you like meet certain people and they
just like are not what they are you know
what I mean on like stage it just is
such a shock and a disappointment and
it's not you know maybe it's not
everybody you can call ignorance and
stuff like that but like I think it's a
two-way street for those people who
understand that they are also recognized
as Legends you do kind of have to like
you gotta play your [__] role you
know what I mean you don't have to like
you know the people who are fans you but
you gotta at least be respectful enough
so that they can continue to be fancy
it's also how he did it it's like I
would have appreciate it that's how he
felt and if he came to one of us it was
like y'all are doing it wrong like let
me give you some guidance rather than do
like a [__] slam book out of Mean
Girls like yeah or or I Get the Era to
like get on these forums like maybe have
a conversation but like not pick a side
because when you're again when you're
like a legend of something you know what
I mean you
on on a culture that's defined by like
inclusive love like I I think it's very
specific when you're talking about dance
culture in general you know what I mean
it's something that's like kind of about
like oppression it's about like you know
breaking the barriers between like
racial language religious divide or
economic and social class like it's like
the foundation and it's generation of it
is the the creation of it is based on
such ideal like foundations you can't I
don't know I just feel like the heroes
and the Legends shouldn't be doing that
kind of stuff because you really just
destroy a lot of you gotta support the
culture yeah you just it's just not
right and I only say this because like
there's a concept in the dance world and
I'm pretty sure it's applicable to a lot
of different like deep Niche cultures
but like there's this concept of like
bitter ogs you know what I mean yeah
right people that like did definitely
and respectfully put in the legwork to
create something but when the world
changes if they don't keep up with it or
like other people are able to take the
mantles and fly further with their
current resources it's a blame game it's
not ever like a a mature understanding
or acceptance like these are the times
and like maybe I can either be a part of
it and participate support and or
whatever it's just like a why it's not
even mature enough to be like why do
they have these opportunities it's more
like you don't deserve these because and
that happens so much in like the
quote-unquote bitter OG game that it's
just it's just off-putting you know what
I mean I think bitter ogs exist in
everything that's what I'm saying I
think it's applicable to like so many
cultures to even be considered an OG and
so far that you can be called a bitter
OG that already should say enough about
like the the lack of just Evolution that
your mind has well look there's there's
this inherent like thing about maturity
that people bake into the OG thing oh
geez didn't ask to be ogs they didn't
even know what the [__] they were
getting they're just good they were just
good at the time yeah of what they were
doing and then people do this [__] to
them where it's like you're like the
Gandhi of this thing and like you're
saying like you found out that he has
flaws and he's a human and he gets
jealous as [__] which is okay like that
nothing about him as a person but just
let's take the statues down because like
these cats are the same as us right like
and I think we all do that though we all
do that right that is true it's like of
course he has a right to be whatever
[__] guy yeah we can still separate
the two right like artistry-wise still
[__] absolute legendary can't [__]
compete with that like he couldn't lock
he could pop but he couldn't lock
but then but then the fact that it can
get close enough to understanding like
you know and I'm not talking about just
him particularly I'm talking about any
of us any of us susceptible to it you
know what I mean even the way that like
whether quests or can just be looked at
in a certain way it's like if we don't
act accordingly if we don't like support
in the way that we were supported not
the ways that we weren't supported but
like you know if we don't support others
in the way we're supported it's like
same [__] we're just gonna be better oh
geez that don't [__] get like what's
going on with the scene You Know spoken
like a bitter Shoemaker cobbler
[Music]